[Music]
in kids being kids news it's been Keith
Smith simony by that's one guy not to a
guy not to which guys is that one not
one that with a mustache parents have a
two-year-old boy we're shocked to find
their son has shredded a stack of cash
they were saving oh my god sometimes
leave the shutter on to I said he might
like it's like it within his reach
there's only one thing to do get rid of
that child it's only like a little bit
of money come on how much is it wasn't
it like a thousand or something for
someone might be a lot it depends on
their financial situation it to get rid
of it it could be a lot get rid of that
child so that's no daughters in Thailand
for like 40 bucks imagine that's like I
don't know how many daughters at is in a
thousand dollars it was a little girls I
think two and a half and a little Thai
shredder two and a half Hey damn dude
that's crazy I would [ __ ] tell that
kid that he has to pay like for the rest
of his life
I'll prospect rails and dock yeah I'll
stack interest on that [ __ ] I'm like
when you were two what you now you're
80% with all the interest yeah dude I'm
a I'm a mobster that kid like I'm gonna
put some 40% and I just keep like yeah
man you owe me for this you owe me for
that you only follow your heart e yep
when you guys here thousand dollars what
do you think about buying I think about
putting it on black and letting that
just spin and see what the [ __ ] happens
when you're a responsible human being
when you think about a thousand dollars
how do you think about like like a
bobble no hotel okay normal [ __ ] you
don't just [ __ ] throw without bells
yeah I'm like I would probably pay my
debt with that hmm like one actual
object versus I didn't you know I'm
putting on the [ __ ] black is a little
different
really I see it as the same thing really
a thousand dollar purse that's
ridiculous no but you get to use it you
enjoy it for like that's utility I use
might get to enjoy it for the 15 seconds
the balls bouncing around yeah I never
did a thousand by this seven hundred
thousand Rhonda and he went to 1,400 Wow
mm-hm honestly I think all the things
that I like are so [ __ ] expensive
that it's all over a thousand so if I
just had a thousand I'll just save it
because anything that would get my
jollies in a Wally and I would probably
need like her to the safe before bro
don't you look at me like it's a saying
that everybody knows anything that's
gonna give my jollies in a lobby is
gonna be more than the dogs have to get
their wiggles out oh yes I said that
Joseph Biggles oh I understand always
talking about those came from Jess oh
she's a wiggly he's a wiggly asian man a
little wiggly Asian man yeah why
emphasize the little huh did say Wiggly
asian man
no he's a wiggly strong Asian man now
she's had a little stable wiggly Asian
man okay we have the source here Jess
what can you repeat what you called it
yeah he's a little
yeah so this tweet went viral Oh looks
like weed how do you set it up so the
tweet says so me and my wife had been
saving up to pay for our at Utah
football tickets and cash we pulled our
money out yesterday to pay my mom for
the season
well we couldn't find the envelope until
my wife checked the shredder yep two
year old shredded 1060 dollars oh look
at this little kid did he's so cute
that's the kid you should keep I had so
much fun just shredding one out of time
he did it like in stacks because you
could see like in the in the strips it's
like a lot of them yeah shredding is fun
I give it to the know a lot of kids look
Asian because they don't develop the
fold
eyes until like yeah as they grow a
video of the parents beating his ass you
know that's what I thought too
can't you go to the [ __ ] bank and no
it has to be 50% of these holding this
shredder we started laughing she's a
super straight out he does not look to
what the bike he looks like he's four
years old with no friends yeah with lots
of friends so if you go to the bank and
you got all the shreds and he taped it
all together you can't even if you taped
it to you know well what if you were
still working at the bank and it was a
homey though I can't cuz he check your
box yeah that a friend so they can get
their money back
oh wow yeah act like she knows
everything
well maybe not a bank but they
say that the Federal Reserve they have a
special Department for money that's for
money that has been destroyed
oh so they're saying that they have to
put all this money into the shredder
below and then they have to send it in
and then they'll take about two or three
years to get their money back though but
they can get their money back I never
heard of that this process I've ever
heard of my life
[ __ ] the Federal Reserve everything
federal government they were sponsored
why are they even taking our taxes I
know I like if I went to like the
federal or wherever I called them up
right I have this money that's destroyed
they're like cool we can fix it seven
years from now all right goodbye
I'd be so [ __ ] mad dude you know
inflation like there's nothing it's
gonna be worth like 700 bucks or some
[ __ ] by the time you get it back at
least you get something back though
you'll get a little surprise into you
that's like the IRS too if you miss a
payment like we need it tomorrow if you
missed a deadline
you're [ __ ] we're gonna send
collections and then if they mess up
they're gonna give your money back like
wait two years we'll send it yeah
they're so good and on your case when
they need some [ __ ] and then when it's
your turn
where are they yeah where the [ __ ] are
they they're saying you'll take six
months to three years not bad I guess
six months the reason I just picture
like guys like with just that's like
doing this one by one just putting it
together with that with a little pliers
and [ __ ] yeah that the [ __ ] you know
the whole you owe money to the IRS thing
call thing like I [ __ ] got that [ __ ]
cuz it was a nine one six number so I
was it could be like you mean those
scams yeah dude it was so [ __ ]
annoying I should have recorded that
conversation but I was like in the car
but he was like you owe exile how much
money do I owe
right and he goes you owe a thousand a
thousand dollars that's it I started
laughing cuz it was so it was such a
dumb number you know as I started this
is not a funny matter you should not be
laughing and I'm just cracking the [ __ ]
up and had an Indian accent - nothing I
think it was just regular old English or
maybe I'll just laughing too hard I
couldn't remember it but it was such a
ridiculous name was like a thousand
bucks
I was like get the [ __ ] out of here the
old English like he was at like thigh
excuse me say ye Oh a thousand shekels
but that [ __ ] was so odd you would think
it would be a more feasible number but
it was like a thousand dollars a lot of
normal people don't really owe taxes
like they get tax returns yeah so like
for he's just they're just shooting out
numbers right they're like oh you owe
$1,000 cuz to a lot of people that is a
lot of money I know I just literally
said thank you rich dude how much money
you gotta do $1,000 brochure yeah that
doesn't even pay my food bill for a week
yeah sometimes I just bought gold or not
you own that [ __ ] dude you're so rich
baby yeah that's why I bought the Honda
that car is breaking down on me by the
way by the horn yo cemani Sequoia how
many Honda cars go off-roading and stuff
I didn't see a single one not one I saw
one broken down on the side of the road
well Honda made for going off-roading
where they made four is made to be on
the road and traveling and getting your
ass kicked by other people
hey that's why I'm training right now
just in case there's so much it happens
if they see my car me playing the flute
inside a big [ __ ] car man the other
ACS like me and David combined into one
car I refuse to get on that car though
element yeah dude that's pretty crazy
like I I I think like when I was younger
like way younger like in my teens a
thousand dollars was a lot of [ __ ]
money yeah 20 bucks was still a lot of
money for me dude it but I think the
whole time become like you raise a
family and all that [ __ ] like a thousand
dollars is still a lot cuz it's hard to
come by but it's like it's it's like it
goes away like that like you could spend
in like that like back then I bought a
car that was like $1,000 a car that's
like yeah he said like a Nissan 200sx
yeah that was like a 8087
I do him loved him said I do remember
when I first joined the military when I
was like 19 you know I was like work
should I go active duty or whatever
hey Dad you know if I stay in the
military it'd be five to ten years from
now I could probably make like 70 grand
a year and my mind it was a lot of money
right but therefore my dad who was even
making that amount he laughed at me and
he was like you think that's a lot
because wait till you have a house and
car payment and yeah but kid goes that
money goes fast I think as at that time
when you don't have too many expenses
you're like well you're tripping but
then later on yeah cuz you don't paint a
bills [ __ ] yeah and everyone else
does right so your life once you have
bills you're like [ __ ] money goes fast
there's a man [ __ ] no kids and [ __ ]
everything is just free for all right
now you [ __ ] not pay for that and
that pay for that watch when the kid
comes in but they can't go started that
yeah but then it's called investing you
have your farm right and you have your
kids like your [ __ ] fear at achill
for I'm not a real farm right it's
called a house coming from you we never
know what you're doing is raising future
workers for you I just want my here
Brian they'll [ __ ] take care of you I
want to live lavish but I want my kids
to live minimal what are you doing right
now in your life to live lavish look at
the bottom of your [ __ ] socks show
everyone the bottom of your socks why is
it holy no I got some tape on appreciate
it but you know what this is lavish the
Haynes extremes yep
yo man you guys don't think I'm lavish
unless Davis very lavish pretty lavish
I'm looking at everything you have you
live
David you leave my socks on and this is
what the [ __ ] is on his feet this what
the [ __ ] is a middle-class right so does
that mean you want your children to grow
up in poverty level yes I want my kids I
think worse than you did I want my kids
to have the exact same things I had or
worse yes or worse so they're not even
gonna have a they're gonna grow up and
be like man dad you a [ __ ] cuz they
grew up worse than you yeah I want my
kids no I just want them to have the
exact same things I have I want them to
go to school I want them to get the
[ __ ] black new supply store I wanted
to get yelled at robbed
I want you have two kids are you gonna
do it exactly the same where your first
kid has a photo album that's this
stacked and the second kid has no
pictures I love a [ __ ] out of the first
one
my brother has like three photo albums
and I have this one little skinny one
it's just so say my bobby and ugly ask
you
I was cutest [ __ ] I turned ugly okay
joke's on you Qi reversed the reverse
not going there like oh you're just a
goose no you've been a goose the whole
time
you're just an ugly cous
[Music]
[Music]